surrounded by heavy security and the
media President Vladimir zielinski
visited the town of butcher near Kiev
after witnessing the devastation he made
a promise that Justice would be done
his war crimes that will be recognized
as genocide by the world you're here and
you see what has happened we know about
thousands killed and tortured people
with cut limbs women who have been raped
and children have been murdered we know
there's so much more this is genocide
on March 10th people here began to bury
the dead in a 45-foot trench dug in the
grounds of a church some 68 bodies at
first some victims of war others who
died of natural causes
the priest of Saint Andrew's Church says
he had to negotiate with the Russians
who occupied butcher to allow the
burials but as the war dragged on more
burials in total 130 were buried her
and the mass grave was needed all across
butcher the deadly in the streets for
days even weeks even now they wait to be
picked up by overworked Undertakers
at the burial site people had wrapped
some of the bodies in black plastic a
little dignity and death
the families took some Solace and the
fact that they were buried next to the
church many had come to be wed or attend
Sunday service before the war today
the priest leans on his faith to deal
with what he's witnessed there is a lot
of hatred and Injustice that people feel
but Christians should forgive but to
forgive doesn't mean to forget we can't
judge Only God can judge some bodies
have been moved from the mass grave to
morgs in and around the town since
butcher was retaken by Ukrainian forces
I'm here looking for my brother we were
close we talked every day but until now
I don't know where his body is
I'm going to try the morgue someone sent
me a picture and told me I need to come
to identify him I hope he is there this
is likely to be one of the largest
burial sites in the town but is by no
means the only one in fact across of
this city people were burying their dead
wherever they could in their backyards
in common areas anywhere where they
might be able to give their dead some
dignity and some respect
standards the Ukraine's attorney general
in Kiev Gathering evidence of potential
war crimes is now the priority
we started in our investigations
actually from
24th of February this year and now we
have more than 4 000 just cases about
war crimes and near 2000 cases which are
connected to war crimes now these days
all words speak about butcher airplane
and in butcher Justice for war crimes is
a concern for the future the dead have
seen the end of War but those Left
Behind are desperate medicines and food
are in limited Supply and what is
available is quickly grabbed by those
who have little of their old lives left
Imran Khan Al Jazeera butcher
well Imran has just come back from bucha
he's joining us from Kiev Imran tell us
more about what you saw in bucha and
what people were telling you
well bucha is a town that is absolutely
scarred uh anybody you speak to in that
town that survived the war and the
occupation from the Russians will tell
you pretty much the same thing that they
thought almost every day that they were
going to die some of the destruction
around the town as you just saw in my
report is almost complete other places
less scarred but still many frightened
people the big there's two kind of
things going on right now for the
residents of butcher it's about the
immediate uh aftermath it's about
getting medicines and food and being
able to make sure that they are able to
look after themselves and their houses
are repaired for the Ukrainian
authorities butcher is now the site of
where they need to find evidence of war
crimes potential war crimes atrocities
uh and they are now Gathering testimony
they're using the police they're using
journalists who have been on the site
they're talking to as many people as
they can to try and build case now the
Attorney General there she also told us
that not only do they have 4 000 cases
related to war crimes but they're also
now looking to prosecute as many people
as they can within Ukraine itself they
have a number of what they call them
captured Russian soldiers if they can
prove that those Russian soldiers have
committed war crimes in the country they
will be prosecuted under Ukrainian law
this may well take a very long time but
like I say there's two things going on
right now if you're an a Ukrainian
resident particularly of butcher
Olympian Osterville in this area and uh
your priority now is to try and get your
life back together but for the Ukrainian
authorities it's all about the future
and any future criminal prosecutions
they can bring thank you so much Imran
Imran is reporting from Kiev
well the U.S President Joe Biden has
also weighed in and he says that there's
ample evidence of atrocities by Russia
he wants Vladimir Putin to be tried for
war crimes
he is a war criminal but we have to
gather the information we have to
continue to provide Ukraine with the
weapons they need to continue the fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be a actual have a war crime
trial this guy is brutal and what's
happening in the Buca is outrageous and
everyone's seen it let's bring in my
Canada joining us from the white house
so that was a a strongly worded remarks
by President Biden Mike
indeed the carefully chosen use of the
word brutal basically a first what
President Biden referring to Vladimir
Putin but making very clear his belief
that Vladimir Putin himself should go on
trial for war crimes now this is a
complicated issue the war crime
situation is something that is a legal
definition it can only be declared after
a series of Investigations and
background information but President
Biden getting ahead of all of that
saying very clearly he believes or
doubling down his belief that war crimes
have been committed and adding as well
that President Putin himself Bears
responsibility for that and he himself
should be tried for war crimes now
President Biden was asked directly
whether he agrees that genocide has
taken place in Ukraine he wouldn't be
drawn on that particular issue once
again genocide is a very tightly
controlled term that depends on legal
situations and is something that
requires a great deal of Investigation
before it can be declared so President
Biden on that particular issue playing
it safely refusing to be drawn into
commenting on whether or not there has
been a genocide in Ukraine as the
Ukrainian president himself has alleged
in recent days but still very strong
words from President Biden in particular
relating to Vladimir Putin himself thank
you Mike mykanna reporting from the
White House
Let's cross over to Moscow because
Russia has rejected all allegations and
says the videos of the bodies in bucha
are staged listen
[Music]
another faked Act was arranged in the
city of butcher in Kiev region after the
Russian military left from there in
accordance with the plans and agreements
reached there was a staging there a few
days later which is widely promoted now
through all channels and social networks
by Ukrainian representatives and their
Western patrons more on that with dorsa
Jabari who's joining us from Moscow so
tell us more about what the kremlins
have been saying
well according to the Kremlin
spokesperson Dmitry peskov the Russians
are categorically denying any
involvement in what they're being
accused of the spokesperson said earlier
on Monday that the Russian forces left
Butcher on March 30th and that when they
left that City everything was in order
according to the Russian defense
Ministry Dimitri peskov also said that
there are indications that the footage
that has come out of that area could
possibly show inconsistencies in the
narrative that is put forth by the
Ukrainian officials suggesting that the
footage is possibly fake he urged the
International Community to not to rush
to any judgments and to allow the
Russian officials to present their
evidence when it comes to the events
that unfolded in those towns around the
Ukrainian Capital he said that
unfortunately this is a another example
of the massive misinformation campaign
that that has been waged against the
Russians and their military forces since
they went into Ukraine on February 24th
we've also been hearing from the Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavrov who in a
meeting following with officials from
the Arab League who are in the Russian
Capital the foreign minister said that
unfortunately this is not the first time
that the Ukrainian officials have
accused the Russian military of carrying
out these atrocities and it's in line
with the narrative that has been put
forth by the Western countries pushing
Ukraine to try and accuse Russia
of carrying out these acts in Ukraine
which they say
again is part of this fake
misinformation campaign
okay dorsa thank you so much there's a
Jabari reporting from Moscow